liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich begrüße auch heute morgen auf der
Ehrentribüne
die frühere Präsidentin der freien
Volkskammer der DDR Frau Dr Bergmann
Pohl
sowie den früheren Bundestagspräsidenten
dr wolfgang Thierse
begrüße auch sehr herzlich Frau Schäuble
und Familie und weitere Weggefährten auf
der Ehrentribüne herzlich willkommen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der 13
dezember
1972 ist ein besonderes Datum in unserer
Geschichte an diesem Tag hat der
Deutsche Bundestag zum ersten Mal eine
Frau zur Präsidentin gewählt die Zeitung
das Parlament Titel damals
der zweite Mann im Staat eine Frau
nicht nur im geteilten Deutschland war
dies eine Premiere
annemarie Renger war weltweit die erste
Frau an der Spitze eines frei gewählten
Parlaments
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Wahlbeteiligung lag 1972 bei traumhaften
91,1 Prozent
der Frauenanteil im Parlament allerdings
war so niedrig wie jemals zuvor und
übrigens auch danach
zu Beginn der siebten Wahlperiode
gehörten nur 30 Frauen den Bundestag an
5,8 Prozent der Abgeordneten
in ihrer Antrittsrede sagte annemarie
Renger die Wahl einer Frau für das Amt
hat verständlicherweise einiges Aufsehen
erregt
das erstmalige und mit hin ungewohnte
Gerät in die Gefahr zum einmaligen und
besonderen erhoben zu werden Zitat Ende
in der Tat dauerte es zwölf Jahre bis
Rita Süßmuth
eine Frau wiederum an der Spitze des
Bundestages war und nach Rita süßmut
dauerte es sogar 23 Jahre bis zur
dritten Bundestagspräsidentin heute
nehmen Frauen selbstverständlich ihren
Platz in der Politik und in der
Gesellschaft ein und das verdanken wir
auch der parlamentarischen Pionierarbeit
von annemarie Renger
sie ebnete Frauen den Weg in die Politik
und in der Politik annemarie Renger
nutzte ihre Stellung als
Bundestagspräsidentin um wie sie selbst
sagte der Sache der Frauen zu dienen sie
wusste politisches Engagement und
Familienleben lassen sich nur
vereinbaren wenn die Rahmenbedingungen
passen das gilt auch heute und nicht nur
im Parlament für annemarie Renger
gehörte dazu den Frauen der
Bundestagsverwaltung die Vereinbarkeit
von Familie und Beruf zu ermöglichen die
Eröffnung der bundestagskita im Jahr
1970 geht auch auf ihre Initiative
zurück
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Frauenanteil ist mit knapp 35 Prozent
auch im aktuellen 20 Bundestag zu
niedrig
Frauen sind auch heute in
Führungspositionen unterrepräsentiert
sie verdienen oft weniger sie leisten
mehrheitlich die kehrarbeit mit allen
Folgen der Weg zur echten Gleichstellung
ist noch weit annemarie Renger kann uns
aber mit ihrer Beharrlichkeit Vorbild
sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen annemarie
Renger wurde 1919 geboren im Jahr der
Einführung des Frauenwahlrechts ihr
sozialdemokratisches Elternhaus stand in
Opposition zum Nationalsozialismus nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg wurde Kurt
Schumacher ihr politischer Mentor und
vertrauter
37 Jahre gehörte sie dem Deutschen
Bundestag ununterbrochen an sie war die
erste parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
der SPD-Fraktion vier Jahre
Bundestagspräsidentin und 14 Jahre
vizepräsidentin
ihr half dabei dass sie eine gehörige
Portion Selbstbewusstsein besaß wie sie
sagte als Abgeordnete behielt sie immer
ihren eigenen Kopf nicht immer zur
Freude ihrer Fraktion
den Deutschen Bundestag führte sie
souverän mit natürlicher Autorität und
mit Charme Annemarie Ringer hat nicht
nur bewiesen dass Frauen es können sie
prägte die damalige Politik in vielen
Fragen sie führte Bürgergespräche im
ganzen Land sie trieb die
parlamentsreform voran sie etablierte
den wissenschaftlichen Dienst des
Deutschen Bundestages sie stärkte das
petitionswesen und intensivierte die
Arbeit der onkett-kommissionen ihre
Herzensangelegenheit war die Aussöhnung
mit Polen und Israel 14 Jahre lang
leitete sie die deutsch-israelische
Parlamentariergruppe
der glücklichste Augenblick ihres
politischen Lebens war aber für sie der
9 November
1989 als die Nachricht vom Fall der
Mauer sich verbreitete leitete sie
gerade als Vizepräsidentin die Beratung
im Bundestag in Bonn
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen annemarie
Renger war als Bundestagspräsidentin
auch deshalb so erfolgreich weil sie
einen feinhumor besaß in ihrer
Antrittsrede würdigte sie die jungen
Abgeordneten mit folgenden Worten ich
zitiere in unserer Mitte begrüße ich die
neuen Mitglieder dieses Hauses die mit
ihrer großen Anzahl jüngerer
Abgeordneten zum ersten Mal des
Durchschnittsalter des Bundestages unter
die 50 Jahresgrenze gedrückt haben Zitat
Ende
und damit begrüßte annemarie Renger auch
sie lieber Kollege Schäuble sie waren
gerade 30 Jahre alt ein promovierter
Jurist und Finanzbeamter
wenn ich auf ihr Lebenswerk Blicke kann
ich eins kaum glauben nach eigener
Auskunft waren sie eigentlich ein
verlegenheitskandidat der CDU in ihrem
Wahlkreis
seit einem halben Jahrhundert gehören
sie nun ununterbrochen im Deutschen
Bundestag an das ist einmalig in der
gesamten Geschichte des deutschen
Parlamentarismus das ist eine Ära
sie haben sogar august-bebel übertroffen
denn nur 44 Jahre reist das Abgeordneter
war
lieber Herr Schäuble ihre Wählerinnen
und Wähler haben Sie 14 Mal in Folge mit
einem Direktmandat betraut und ihnen
damit das Vertrauen geschenkt das
wichtigste Kapital in einer
parlamentarischen Demokratie sie haben
die Geschicke unseres Landes in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten wie nur wenige
geprägt als Kanzleramtsminister haben
sie maßgeblich die deutsch-deutschen
Beziehungen gestaltet als Innenminister
unter Helmut Kohl haben sie den
Einigungsvertrag entworfen und den
wiedervereinigungsprozess entscheidend
mit gelenkt sie sind zum Architekten der
deutschen Einheit geworden als
Innenminister unter Angela Merkel haben
Sie zum Beispiel die Islamkonferenz ins
Leben gerufen ein Meilenstein in der
Integrationspolitik
als Finanzminister haben sie Deutschland
und Europa durch die Finanz-
Präsident haben Sie beispielsweise die
deutsch-französische Parlamentarische
Versammlung etabliert und mit dem
Bürgerrat ein neues Instrument zur
Belebung unserer Demokratie auf den Weg
gebracht
für mich sind sie ganz besonders ein
großer Europäer der sich mit
Leidenschaft und aus tiefster
Überzeugung für die Einheit Europas
einsetzt dieses Engagement wurde
übrigens auch im Jahr 2012 mit dem
Karlspreis gewürdigt
Angela Merkel hat ihre politischen
Verdienste einmal so zusammengefasst
Wolfgang Schäuble ist ein Glücksfall für
die deutsche und europäische Politik
wie annemarie Renger haben sie sich
immer mit unglaublicher Disziplin und
großen Pflicht und
Verantwortungsbewusstsein in den Dienst
unseres Staates gestellt und mit Freude
an der Politik in einer Festschrift
wurden sie einmal als fröhlicher
Sisyphus betitelt ich denke mit dieser
Beschreibung können Sie ganz gut leben
lieber Herr Schäuble nicht ohne Grund
gelten sie als ein Mann der Exekutive
ihre Gestaltungskraft und ihr
Gestaltungsdrang sind berühmt ich habe
jetzt einige Wegmarken ihres Wirkens
erwähnt zugleich sind sie aber bis heute
Parlamentarier aus Leidenschaft
sie kennen den Bundestag aus
verschiedenen Perspektiven als einfacher
Abgeordneter parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer Fraktionschef
Oppositionsführer Alterspräsident und
Bundestagspräsident und in jeder dieser
Position waren sie ein großer Verfechter
des demokratischen Streits im Respekt
vor dem Gegenüber als
Fraktionsvorsitzender waren sie einen
gefürchteter debattenredner ihr Wort hat
Gewicht und Überzeugungskraft ihre
mitreißende Rede in der
berlin-bondebatte am 20 Juni 1991 ist
dafür ein starkes Beispiel
ihre plenarrede war eine der
entscheidenden reden die am Ende zum
Beschluss für Berlin als Parlaments und
Regierungssitz führte und ihnen ganz
nebenbei auch die Ehrenbürgerschaft der
Hauptstadt einbrachte
[Gelächter]
Streit ist das Salz der Demokratie das
war immer ihre Devise zum konstruktiven
Streit haben sie uns Abgeordnete als
Parlamentspräsident auch immer ermuntert
auch in herausfordernden Zeiten sie
haben das Parlament immer angehalten
gegensätzliche Standpunkte auch
auszuhalten den politischen Streit haben
sie nie als Selbstzweck verstanden
sondern als ein Instrument und
widerstreitende Interessen in Rede und
Gegenrede zu artikulieren und bei
drängenden Zukunftsfragen auch wirklich
voranzukommen
über den Bundestag haben sie gesagt ich
zitiere hier ist der Ort an dem wir
streiten dürfen an dem wir streiten
sollen fair und nach Regeln
leidenschaftlich aber auch mit der
Gelassenheit die einer erregten
Öffentlichkeit Beispiel geben könnte
Zitat Ende
lieber Herr Schäuble auch nach 50 Jahren
dienen sie den Parlament mit ihrer
unvergleichlichen Erfahrung mit ihrer
Weitsicht und ihrem intellektuellen
Scharfsinn wir sind jetzt gespannt auf
ihre Ausführung Herr Schäuble sie haben
das Wort
so wird sich also der Jubilar jetzt noch
mal selbst zu Wort melden im Parlament
dem er seit 50 Jahren angehört ein
allzeitrekord keiner ist auch nur
annähernd an diese Zeit gekommen in der
Geschichte nationaler deutscher
Parlamente sei es der Reichstag oder der
Bundestag und jetzt Wolfgang Schäuble
frau Präsidentin
für die Kollegen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
ich bedanke mich sehr für ihre
sehr
mich ehrende
Würdigung
und auch für die
für Ihr Angebot hier
einiges einige Worte sagen zu dürfen
annemarie Renger
war eine
allzeit respektierte
Bundestagspräsidentin sie haben sie
zu Recht eben gewürdigt
annemarie Renger achtete streng auf die
Würde des Hauses
so wie man sie damals verstanden als
einmal als sozialdemokratischer Kollege
ohne Krawatte im Plenum saß
[Gelächter]
da ließ sie ihm durch ein
parlamentsassistenten unauffällig einen
Winter bringen und der hatte noch
widerspruchslos angelegt
ich kann mich übrigens nicht erinnern
dass die Tatsache dass eine Frau das Amt
inne hatte mir besonders bemerkenswert
erschienen wäre
vielleicht war manches vor 50 Jahren
doch schon selbstverständlicher als
heute viele glauben
gewöhnungsbedürftig für uns in der Union
war allerdings das erstmal seine
sozialen Demokratin das Amts ausübt
aber das ist ja heute auch keine
Besonderheit mehr
übrigens hatte 1972 der erste Bericht
des klappers
zu den Grenzen des Wachstums schon die
Gefahren von exponentiell wachsenden
Ressourcen für Ressourcenverbrauch und
Umweltbelastung aufgezeigt er hat auch
viel Aufmerksamkeit erfahren auch bei
mir
aber er hat leider zu wenig praktische
Schlussfolgerungen gefunden
auch deswegen verstehe ich warum die
junge Generation heute so drängt
und ich sehe die Herausforderung für die
parlamentarische Demokratie zu erklären
warum in der freiheitlichen Gesellschaft
Prozesse oft langsam verlaufen
1973 folgte übrigens schon die erste
Energiekrise
weil damals die
Objekt die Arab die von den Objekt die
war damals von den arabischen Staaten
dominiert die wollten mit einer
Verknappung der Ölförderung den Westen
zu einer weniger Israel freundlichem
Politik zwingen wir hatten in der
Adventszeit
1973 Fahrverbote wir sind auf der
Autobahn Fahrrad gefahren und und uns
spazieren gegangen
der einspar beim Ölverbrauch war
übrigens auch damals gering
meine Partei meine Partei hatte im
Wahlkampf 1972
sie haben eben noch die Wahlbeteiligung
zu Recht erwähnt vor allem die
anzeigende Inflation mit ihren Gefahren
für Wachstum und Beschäftigung
thematisiert
und irgendwie hatten wir im Beifall
unsere Anhängerin Wahlkampf gar nicht
richtig mitbekommen dass manche Reformen
das soziale Liberalen Koalition 69 bis
72 in einer Gesellschaft die sich in der
Nachkriegszeit zunächst vor allem auf
das Wirtschaftswunder konzentriert hat
und Zustimmung fanden
und vor allem hatten wir nicht
verstanden dass die Fortschreibung der
Westintegration mit der neuen Ost und
Deutschlandpolitik der begrenzten
Zusammenarbeit unter der Überschrift
Mandel durch Annäherung nicht nur mit
dem Friedensnobelpreis für Willy Brandt
sondern auch mit wachsender Zustimmung
in der öffentliche Meinung honoriert
wurde man sieht
auch wenn heute alles ganz anders zu
sein scheint als vor 50 Jahren so ist
doch auch nicht alles ganz neu
nach meinen Erfahrungen bin ich mir
übrigens auch nicht so sicher dass aus
Anfang
idealistischem Protest mit einer anfängt
zu strafbaren Mittel zu greifen liegt
auch schlimme Entscheidungen und
Entwicklungen entstehen können und
deswegen ist es gut wenn unsere
zuständigen Behörden hier auch hier den
Anfängen wehren
auch wenn sich
auch wenn sich die Geschichte nicht
wiederholt lassen sich aus der
distanzierten Betrachtung von
Entwicklungen ja Entscheidungshilfen für
Gegenwart und Zukunft gewinnen die
Bereitschaft zur zusammenarbeiten und
Partnerschaft darf nicht zum verzichter
verteidigungsabschreckungsfähigkeit
Führen das haben wir nach Putins
Überfall auf die Ukraine wieder lernen
müssen es stand so schon im
h-moll-bericht der NATO von 1967 und wir
hatten dann die gesellschaftliche
Debatte Ende der 70er Anfang der 80er
Jahre nachdem Helmut Schmidt 79 in der
NATO den sogenannten doppelbeschluss
durchgesetzt hatte der wollte eine Lücke
in der Glaubwürdigkeit der Abschreckung
schließen weil die Sowjetunion mit
Raketen mittlerer Reichweite die nur
Europa aber nicht Amerika erreichen
konnten ein Bedrohungspotenzial
geschaffen hatte
von Themen Helmut Schmidt und dann auch
die NATO überzeugt waren dass es
entweder beseitigt werden oder durch
eine entsprechende Aufstellung von
Waffensystemen mit mittlerer Reichweite
in Europa ausgeglichen werden müssen an
diesem doppelbeschluss hat Helmut
Schmidt die Unterstützung seiner Partei
verloren der Widerstand richtet sich
sich bemerkenswerterweise nicht gegen
die auf uns gerichteten sowjetischen
Raketen sondern gegen die zu unseren
Schutz notfalls zu treffenden Maßnahmen
meines Erachtens gehört zu den großen
Leistungen von Bundeskanzler Kohl nach
dem Regierungswechsel 82
dass er diesen NATO-Doppelbeschluss
gegen heftigen öffentlichen Widerstand
vollzogen hat vielleicht wäre die
Geschichte
vielleicht wäre die Geschichte mit
Michael Gorbatschow ohne diese
Entscheidung anders verlaufen jedenfalls
hat uns Putin jetzt gezeigt dass wir
auch im 21 Jahrhundert in Frieden nur
sichern können wenn wir auch in der Lage
sind uns gegebenenfalls zu verteidigen
wir hätten es wissen können wir wollten
es nicht sehen sagte die frühere
Verteidigungsministerin Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer
das ist Bedrohungen durch terroristische
asymmetrische Kriegsführung auch nichts
staatlicher Akteure gibt haben wir am 11
September 2001 mit den Anschlägen auf
das World Trade Center erfahren die
Sicherheit der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wurde danach vom Peters
Druck zu zitieren am hindukus verteidigt
wir haben bis heute keine gute Antwort
gefunden wie wir auf solche Bedrohungen
reagieren sollen in Afghanistan nicht
und jetzt in Mali auch wieder nicht
der Sieg der freiheitlich
rechtsstaatlichen Demokratie den Francis
Fukuyama nach 1990 in seinem Ende der
Geschichte verkündete den hassem
Huntington schon in seinem class of
zivilizations 96 hinterfragt und noch
immer suchen wir nach dem richtigen Maß
an Respekt vor unterschiedlichen
Kulturen
Traditionen und Wertvorstellungen
einerseits und unserer universalen
Verantwortung für Menschenrechte
andererseits jedenfalls haben wir im
Vergleich zu 1972 als für uns in Europa
die Polarität des ostwestkonfliktes
alles andere zu überlagern schien die
größere Vielfalt und zugleich die
größere Vernetzung globaler Strukturen
lernen müssen
und wir sehen im übrigen dass wir uns in
Deutschland und in Europa sehr
anstrengen müssen wenn wir unsere
eigenen Ansprüchen im globalen Ranking
auch nur einigermaßen gerecht werden
wollen vielleicht
müssen wir Deutsche auch aufpassen dass
wir nicht als Besserwisser die ihren
eigenen Ansprüchen selbst nicht gerecht
werden international zu viel Sympathie
verlieren
dafür könnt ihr übrigens auch unsere
doch eher unbefriedigende Auftritt bei
der Fußballweltmeisterschaft in Katar
manchen Beleg leben
verändert hat sich jedenfalls die
öffentliche Kommunikation die sich aus
den Print- und elektronischen Medien
viel stärker in sozialen Netzwerken
verlagert hat mit all den Gefahren für
die Stabilität unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen Grund wird Ordnung die
wir ja fast überall in der Welt wo ich
solche Demokratien überhaupt gibt
beobachten müssen das Vertrauen in die
Fähigkeit von Politik Probleme zu lösen
sozialen Zusammenhalt zu gewähren einen
verlässlichen Rahmen und ausgewogenen
Raum für Freiheit und Sicherheit zu
gewährleisten das nimmt offenbar ab je
mehr wir uns bemühen jedes einzelne
Problem noch besser noch perfekter zu
lösen
ich weiß nicht wie viele
endbürokratisierungskommission und
Initiativen wir in diesen 50 Jahren
hatten besser geworden ist jedenfalls
nichts
Förderalismus Kommission hatten wir zwei
ganz groß angelegte zwischen Bundestag
und Bundesrat und Bundesregierung
aber niemand behauptet ernsthaft dass
die föderale Ordnung unseres Landes die
ja im Grunde
weitgehend unbestritten ist mit
bundländern und kommunaler
Selbstverwaltung derzeit in guter
Verfassung sein
ich will mit ungebetenen Ratschlägen
wirklich zurückhalten das habe ich mir
in meiner Alters und Mandatszeit
begründet und Sonderrolle vorgenommen
deshalb will ich ihr freundliches
Angebot frau Präsidentin heute einige
Worte was in diesen 50 Jahren sich wie
die Entwicklung war ich will das nicht
missbrauchen aber vielleicht ein Gedanke
wie wäre es
wie wäre es wenn wir eine breite
öffentliche Debatte anstoßen würden wie
wir unseren durch
perfektionistische Überregulierung
ähnlich dem gefesselten riesen Gulliver
in zu vielen fast schon handlungsunfähig
gewordenen Staat durch eine grundlegende
Neuordnung der Aufgaben auch zwischen
Staat und Gesellschaft und der
Neuordnung der Zuständigkeiten
einschließlich der Zuordnung von selbst
zu bestimmenden Einnahmen von Bund
Ländern und Kommunen wieder effizienter
machen können
die Nationale Akademie der
Wissenschaften Leopoldina und die
Berlin-Brandenburgische Akademie der
Wissenschaft haben vor kurzem ein
interessanten Anstoß gegeben den könnten
wir aufgreifen und dann könnten wir auf
diesem Weg einer wieder als
handlungsfähig wahrgenommenen Politik
auch das Verständnis der Bürger fördern
das Demokratie eben wie kürzlich ein
Autor geschrieben hat eine Zumutung ist
und nicht ein Supermarkt für
Schnäppchenjäger das ist neben Rechte
auch Pflichten gibt und dass jeder nach
seiner ganz eigenen unterschiedlichen
Entscheidung auch seinen Beitrag für
andere und damit wird das Gemeinwohl
leisten kann leisten muss
wir sollten
auch wir sollten auch gerade in dem
jetzt so oft beschriebenen Wettbewerb
der Systeme bedenken
das bei all unseren Schwächen die
Grundwerte unserer freiheitlich
rechtsstaatlichen Ordnung sich fast
überall da auf der Welt wo diese Werte
nicht verwirklicht sind so großer
Anziehungskraft erfreuen dass die
Unterdrückten sich danach sehnen ihr
Leben riskieren um es vielleicht sich zu
erkämpfen und dass die Diktatoren genau
diese Anziehungskraft fürchten also
tragen wir Verantwortung zu zeigen dass
diese Werte auch funktionieren dass das
besser geht und weil wir so lange es uns
gut zu gehen scheint und schwer tun für
notwendige Änderungen ohne zu viel
Perfektionismus politische Mehrheiten zu
finden bleibe ich auch in der
gegenwärtigen Krise zuversichtlich den
je mehr wir begreifen dass wir nicht
einfach so weitermachen dürfen
umso eher wächst die Chance für
notwendige Änderungen stabile Mehrheiten
zustande zu bringen das ist ja die Lehre
von Karl Poppers offener Gesellschaft
die im Prozess von trial und error doch
immer wieder den Weg zu neuen Lösungen
findet
deshalb sind Krisen immer auch Chancen
und so
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren haben wir Grund zur
Zuversicht und das gilt heute genauso
wie vor 50 Jahren ich danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
Standing Ovations für
Wolfgang Schäuble man muss mit oder
sollte mit historischen Begriffen
vorsichtig sein aber der Bundestag hat
er wirklich ein lebendes Denkmal in
seinen rein er wird ja solange ist er
gewählt den Parlamenten noch bis zum
voraussichtlichen Ende der
Legislaturperiode Ende 2025 erhalten
bleiben wie gesagt Wolfgang Schäuble in
einer Erweiterung seiner Ehrung als
Abgeordneter 50 Jahre Mitglied des
Bundestags noch mal ein allzeit Rekord
kein anderer keine andere hat diesen
Rekord erreicht in der Geschichte
nationaler deutscher Parlamente weder im
Reichstag noch hier im Bundestag
Wolfgang Schäuble
ja und jetzt schließt sich auch noch
eine gratulationskur an die man sonst
eigentlich nur nach der Wahl der
Bundeskanzlerin oder des Bundeskanzlers
kennt das aus allen Fraktionen auch aus
der AFD hier kommt alles weitere Palace
Bild und auch von anderen Fraktionen
natürlich auch
Gratulanten da sind um Wolfgang Schäuble
für 50 Jahre Mitgliedschaft im Bundestag
zu gratulieren vergessen weil wir nicht
das auch die erste Bundestagspräsidentin
annemarie Renger von der SPD heute
geehrt worden ist vorgestern vor 50
Jahren wurde zum ersten Mal eine Frau in
dieses Amt gewählt von den 40 von
Entschuldigung von den 14
Bundestagspräsidenten waren allerdings
in der Parlamentsgeschichte des
Bundestages nur drei Frauen das war
annemarie Renger noch Rita Süßmuth von
1988 bis 1998 und jetzt seit dem
vergangenen Herbst Bärbel Bars die
dieser Sitzung hier auch vorsteht elf
Männer drei Frauen da ist auch im Amt
des
Bundestagspräsidenten und der
Bundestagspräsidentin noch Luft nach
oben
Herr Dr Schäuble ich wusste es lohnt
sich immer ihnen Redezeit einzuräumen
und sie haben sich auch an die
Zeitkontingente gehalten auf das
haben Sie ja selbst als Präsident hier
oben auch immer eingehalten herzlichen
Dank dafür und ich gratuliere Ihnen sie
haben das ja gemerkt im Namen des ganzen
Hauses noch mal ganz ganz herzlich zu
ihrem 50-Jährigen parlamentsjubiläum
[Applaus]